in this video we're going to be going
through a college algebra final exam
review we're going to go through 50
questions in no particular order some of
them are going to be a little bit easier
some are going to be a little bit more
challenging and I'll try to explain the
important Concepts and formulas and
things like that as we go through this
video so feel free to jump around feel
free to pause the video and try some of
the problems on your own first and then
we'll of course go through them together
let's dive into these first couple of
questions so the first one says which
quadrant is point negative 3 comma 2 in
and so this is kind of a basic question
it's like an algebra 1 type question
actually but remember your quadrants
they go in this
Direction like this where this is
quadrant one quadrant two quadrant three
quadrant four and you want to remember
that this is your X and this is your y
so if you start at the origin if x is
negative that means we're going to go
left so we're going left three and the y
coordinate is positive we're going to go
up two and you can see that's putting us
into quadrant two you might also want to
memorize positive positive in the first
quadrant negative positive in the second
negative negative in the third positive
negative in the fourth and just remember
X left and right y up and down so let's
go to the second question this one we're
just solving for x okay so how would you
do that one
now I picked this problem and kind of
made it up actually to try to illustrate
this concept that students sometimes
make a mistake with you see this minus
five here you can think of this as a
negative 5 that you're Distributing or
multiplying into the parentheses so that
gives you a negative 5x a negative times
a negative is a positive so that's plus
five bring down the two
same thing over here we're Distributing
that 3 into the parentheses so that's 3x
minus 12.
and now what I like to do is kind of
simplify you know each side first as
much as I can so the 2 and the 5 I'm
going to combine together so that's
negative 5x plus 7. so that's all kind
of like the first step simplifying the
left and right sides then the second
step you want to get the variables on
one side and the numbers on the opposite
side so you're trying to separate them I
usually like to get the variables on the
left so that means we're going to get
rid of them on the right by doing the
opposite so if I subtract 3x on the
right subtract 3x on the left you can
see we're getting negative 8X plus 7
equals negative 12. now we have the
variables here on the left so to get the
numbers on the right we have to get rid
of them on the left by doing the
opposite so instead of adding 7 we'll
subtract 7
and now you can see we've got negative
12 minus 7 is negative 19. we just want
to solve for 1X this is like the third
and last step and instead of multiplying
by negative 8 you want to then divide by
negative 8. and so you can see that X is
coming out to negative divided by a
negative is a positive 19 8.
okay see if you can try number three and
four these are rational equations so if
I was going to do number three what I
notice is that we've got these
denominators here wouldn't be great if
we could clear the denominators and get
rid of those so what you would do is you
would multiply through this entire
equation by the lowest common
denominator that's the smallest quantity
that x 5 and 2 all go into it in this
case we can see they would all go into
10x so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to multiply this entire equation left
and right sides that keeps it balanced
by 10x or you can think of it as 10x
over 1. when I distribute to each of
these fractions look at what happens
10x times 2 is 20x divided by X is just
going to give us 20. over here 10x times
negative one fifth that's going to give
us negative 2X and then over here this
is going to give us 30X divided by 2
which is 15x so effectively what we did
is we cleared the denominators and if
this is a little bit challenging for you
what you can do is you can put next to
each fraction 10x over 1
10x over 1 at 10x over 1 like this and
then you can do some cross reducing or
you can multiply the numerators together
in denominators and then divide like
that and so that's how you would clear
the denominators we'll do another
example it's a little bit more
challenging with number four
so then here what you want to do is you
want to get the variables on one side
numbers on the other so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to add 2x to
both sides
so you can see that's giving us 20 is
equal to 17x and we just want to solve
for 1X so I'm going to divide both sides
by 17 and you can see that X is equal to
20 over 17. now when you're doing these
rational equations you want to make sure
that you're never dividing by zero
because that's undefined so I just
quickly look back at the denominators if
I plug in 2017s in for X here I can see
that's not going to make the denominator
0. so we know this is a good solution
if it did make it equal to zero that
would be extraneous we'd cross it out
and then there would be like no solution
in this case but in this case this is a
good answer
for number four what would you do on
this one
well the first step is really to factor
all the denominators if you can so this
is a difference of two squares which we
can factor that as x minus 1 X plus one
so I'll just cross that out for now and
then what we're going to do is we're
going to clear the denominators again
but I'm going to show you a little
different technique and that technique
is to get the common denominator the
same denominator for all three of these
fractions so what I notice is I have an
x minus 1 X Plus 1 here I just have an x
minus 1 here so let me multiply the
numerator and denominator by what I'm
missing which is X Plus 1. as long as
you do it to the top and bottom you know
it's still the same fraction it's just
in a different form here we have an X
Plus 1 but we don't have an x minus 1.
so let's go ahead and multiply what
we're missing the x minus 1 to the
numerator and denominator right now we
have a common denominator for all three
of these fractions what we're going to
do is we're going to multiply through
this entire equation by X Plus 1 x minus
1 and that will clear are the
denominators it's keeping the equation
balanced because we're doing it to both
the left and right sides and so when you
clear those denominators by multiplying
through by X Plus 1 x minus 1.
which is like over one we're just
Distributing to each fraction that
clears the denominators and we're just
left with the numerators so 3x minus 2
times X Plus 1 equals four
times x minus 1. now it's a much easier
equation to solve right so what we're
going to do is we're going to do that
same technique of
Distributing the negative 2 into the
parentheses that gives us negative 2x
minus 2. bring down the 3x distribute
the 4 into the parentheses that gives us
4X minus 4 combine like terms so 3x
minus 2x is going to give us just X
and let's see we want to get the
variables on one side numbers on the
other so what I'll do is I'll subtract
4X
and then I'll add two to both sides so
if we do that that gives us negative 3x
the twos cancel and we get negative 2
and we'll just divide by negative 3 to
solve for 1X whatever you do to the left
you want to do to the right the two
negatives cancel so you can see that
we're getting x equals two-thirds but
again you want to go back and make sure
you're not dividing by zero so if x came
out to let's say 1 or negative 1 you'd
be dividing by zero that would be an
extraneous solution you want to cross
that one out but in this case two-thirds
that doesn't make the denominator zero
it's a good answer okay see if you can
do number five and six this one says
solve the equation for x okay so this is
called a rewriting a formula or solving
a literal equation and the thing that
makes this problem tricky is that
there's an X in this term as well as in
this x term so how do we get that X by
itself well the key here is you want to
factor out the X out of both of these
terms so it's kind of like doing the
distributive property backwards instead
of multiplying X in order binding X out
and you can see if we divide both these
by X we're left with 2 plus 3y
and now you can see that X and the
parentheses are right next to each other
side by side that means they're
multiplied together so the opposite of
multiplying by 2 plus 3y is to divide
both sides by 2 plus 3y whatever we do
to the right we want to do to the left
and now you can see that X is equal to W
over the quantity 2 plus 3y
okay now for number six
you invest ten thousand dollars into two
CDs earning three percent and five
percent annual interest after one year
you earn 460 dollars of Interest how
much did you invest in each CD
okay so this one we're trying to solve
for two quantities uh the amount
invested at three percent and five
percent so if you have two unknowns you
need to write a system of equations
involving two variables two equations so
if I was going to do this one we're
going to call the amount invested at
three percent X the amount invested at
five percent why so this is going to be
X Plus y equals ten thousand that's the
total amount invested but point zero
three times X Plus .05 times y equals
the four hundred sixty dollars amount of
interest earned so what you're doing is
you're taking the amount invested times
that percentage to get the interest and
then you're doing the same thing with
the amount invested at five percent okay
so now what I like to do when I have
decimals like this is to clear or get
rid of those decimals and the easiest
way to do that is to multiply everything
by a hundred that'll move the decimal
two places to the right so that's going
to give us 3x plus 5y equals 46
000. now what we can do is we can
eliminate either the X's or the Y's I'm
going to multiply this top equation by
negative 3
so that's going to give us negative 3x
minus 3y is equal to negative
30 000.
and so now when we add straight down you
can see the X's are canceling and we get
2y is equal to 16
000 divide both sides by 2 and Y is
equal to 8 000. so what that means is
that you have eight thousand dollars
invested at five percent and if you plug
it back in here you can see X must be
two thousand to add up to the ten
thousand so two thousand dollars
invested at the three percent CD okay
see if you can do numbers seven and
number eight so for number seven we've
got a radical equation a square root
equation so what you want to do in these
problems is you want to get the square
root by itself on one side of the
equation everything else on the other
side and that's the case here already
then what you want to do is you want to
do the opposite of square rooting which
is to square both sides and here's where
sometimes students make a little bit of
mistake what they'll do is they'll just
Square the X and square the one not
realizing that this is a binomial
squared what you want to think of this
as X plus one
squared meaning times itself like you've
got two of them and then here the square
and the square root those are going to
cancel so you're just going to end up
with a 1 plus 6X on the left side so
here you can either distribute twice or
you can foil however you want to do that
so that's going to come out to x squared
X and 1X that's going to be 2X and then
1 times 1 is 1. and let's just bring
down this one plus six x okay so now we
can see we have a squared term and we
have a first degree term so what I would
do here is I would get everything on one
side of the equation set it to zero so
I'm going to subtract the 1 and the 6x
from both sides so that's going to set
this equal to zero
and this just comes out to 1 minus one
that's just zero okay so now what we
want to do is we want to factor and you
can see that you can factor out a
greatest common factor of X and now that
it's factored we set each of these
factors equal to zero so we say x equals
zero or x minus 4 equals 0 add 4 to both
sides we're getting x equals 0 or x
equals 4. now what you want to do is you
want to check your answer because you
can get a false answer like an
extraneous solution so what you want to
do is you want to go all the way back to
the original equation before we squared
both sides okay so just all the way back
to the original here
and so what we can see is when we put 0
in 6 times 0 is 0 plus 1 is 1. the
square root of one is one so that's one
on the left 0 plus 1 that's 1 on the
right one equals one so we know this is
a good answer let's put in 4 4 plus 1 is
5 on the right 4 times 6 is 24 plus 1 is
25 square root of 25 is 5 so 5 equals
five so this is also a good answer you
could get a situation where one works
and one doesn't or they both don't work
and there's no solution but in this case
they both work so they're both good
answers
okay for number eight now we're moving
on to solving uh absolute value
equations so how do you solve this
absolute value equation well remember
inside of this absolute value before we
take the absolute value it could have
been negative 10 and you take the
absolute value that comes out to 10 or
this could be positive 10 that's the
value of positive 10 would be 10. so
what we do is we split this up into the
two scenarios here that 5x minus 2 could
equal 10 or and a math or means both 5x
minus 2 or Union equals negative 10. so
if we solve these two equations let's
add 2 to both sides
so we get 5x is equal to 12 and over
here we get 5x is equal to negative 8
and then if we divide both sides by 5
to get X by itself
you can see we're getting X is equal to
12 fifths or X is equal to negative
eight fifths again you want to go ahead
and plug it back into the original
equation make sure that it makes the
equation true if we do this let's see 5
times 12 fifths is 12 minus two is ten
absolute value of 10 is equal to 10. so
that's good negative eight fifths gives
us negative 40 fifths which is negative
eight minus two is negative 10 absolute
value of negative 10 is 10. so in this
case you can see both of these answers
are working so they're both good
Solutions okay for number nine and ten
we're going to solve inequalities now so
less than less than or equal to greater
than greater than or equal to and I'd
like for you to write your answer in our
interval notation so you can practice
that as well so for number nine how
would you solve this one
well we've got the absolute value of 2x
minus 1 is greater than 3. now what does
that mean greater than 3 well see if you
think about this as like a distance and
think about it as a distance maybe say
for example from from the origin for or
from zero so if you were greater than
three units from zero what you could
think about greater than means you'd
have to be like three units or further
like actually further than three units
or further than three units this way so
what we do is we split this into two
inequalities we say two x minus one has
to be less than
negative three right or
two x minus 1 has to be greater than
positive three see both of these are
three units
from from zero or from the origin so you
can think of this again like two
inequalities another way students like
to do it is they like to write it just
like you see here 2x minus 1 is greater
than 3. and then the elected to write it
as 2x minus one and they flip this
inequality sign to the other direction
so instead of greater than they make it
less than and they change this to the
opposite so that's just kind of a quick
uh way of doing it but this is just a
more of a graphical way of understanding
it and then you want to remember when
it's greater than it's or and when it's
less than it's and and one way people
remember that is a great Tor sounds like
or less than kind of sounds like and
right so that's just some little hacks
there now if you go ahead and solve both
of these
inequalities here by adding 1 to both
sides let's see it looks like we have
two axes less than negative two and two
x is greater than four divide both sides
by two and you can see we have X is less
than negative one or X is greater than
two now what I like to do before I write
the interval notation is think about
this on a number line like see here's
negative 1 and here's two x is less than
negative 1 or which remember or means
Union X is greater than two so it's all
of these values as well as all these
values so when we write this in interval
notation we go from left to right on the
number line so we start over here at
negative Infinity
so negative Infinity to negative one not
including negative one so we're using
the parentheses Union
2 to Infinity again not including two
not including Infinity you can never
reach infinity and that would be our
interval notation or our solution to
this absolute value inequality
okay so for number 10 now how do you
solve this polynomial inequality
well here what I would do the first step
is I would Factor
as much as I can so this factors to x
minus 6 times x plus one is a less than
or equal to zero and if you need to
review factoring check out some of my
factoring videos
now what you do is you set each of these
factors each of these groups equal to
zero so we say x minus 6 is equal to
zero X plus one is equal to zero add six
to both sides and subtract one from both
sides okay now what we do is we go to
the number line and you want to plot
these points from low to high so the
lowest to the highest and now notice how
it's less than or equal to zero so when
X is equal to six it's equal to zero so
that's going to be closed and if it's
negative one it's going to make this
equal to zero so it's going to be closed
now if this was a less than or greater
than but not equal to then it would be
an open circle like Hollow okay you know
empty not including that point so now
what we want to do is we want to pick
some test values in each one of these
intervals and see if it makes it
less than or equal to zero basically
meaning negative or zero so let's start
off with testing negative two so if I
put negative 2 just into this factored
form I'm going to get negative 8 okay
which is like a negative and negative 2
plus 1 is negative 1 which is a negative
and a negative times a negative is a
positive so I'm just going to put a plus
sign in this region here
if I pick a test Point here let's say
for example zero zero minus 6 is
negative zero plus one is positive one
and a negative times a positive is a
negative so this is called sign analysis
and then you can put it into the whole
thing and see if it's positive or
negative this is just a shortcut and
then if we do let's say 7 in this
interval that's going to be 7 minus 6
which is 1 which is positive and this
gives us 8 which is positive a positive
times a positive it's a positive but we
want it to be less than or equal to zero
meaning where it's negative or zero so
that's going to be right here in this
region so what that tells us if we write
the answer in interval notation it's
going to be from negative 1 to 6. we're
using these square brackets here because
it includes negative 1 and it includes
6. remember the parentheses if it's an
open it doesn't include that point and
another way to look at this as well is
see we're analyzing this on the number
line in one dimension if we were to
think about this
in two Dimensions imagine if this is the
y-axis and the x-axis what we have here
is actually a parabola that's opening up
like this okay something like that and
so we are asking ourselves where is the
graph less than or equal to zero meaning
below the x-axis and you can see right
here that Parabola is below the x-axis
between negative one and six and so
that's how we're getting this solution
but we're doing it in one dimension on
the number line okay how's it going so
far you're able to get a lot of these
correct so keep going see if you can
keep pausing the video and trying these
problems and we'll keep explaining as we
go through so number 11 we've got
another inequality this is called a
rational inequality see how it's like a
ratio or a fraction and we're looking at
where it's greater than or equal to zero
so what I would do on this problem is I
would Factor the numerator and the
denominator as much as I can so in this
case this factors to x minus 4 times X
plus three so I'm just going to replace
that with the factored form now what you
want to do the numerator is already
factored we can't factor that any
further we're going to set these factors
equal to zero so if we do that we've get
X plus 2 is equal to zero x minus 4 is
equal to 0 and x plus three is equal to
zero if we subtract two from both sides
we get negative 2 add 4 to both sides we
get positive four and subtract 3 from
both sides we get negative three we then
go to our number line and remember we
put these in order from lowest to
highest so negative 3 negative two and
four
and notice how this is greater than or
equal to zero now the numerator can be
zero of a fraction so here at negative
two this can equal zero so that's going
to be closed but the denominator cannot
be zero if the denominator is zero
that's undefined so a negative three and
four these have to be open so
denominator always is going to be open
the numerator could be open or closed if
this was greater than but not equal to
all of them would be open okay so now
what we want to do is we want to test
some points in each of the intervals and
you can see we've got one two three four
intervals so let's start with negative
four and so if we put negative 4 in we
get negative four plus two which is
negative two negative four minus 4 is a
negative eight and negative 4 plus 3 is
negative one so a negative times a
negative is a positive and a negative
divided by a positive is a negative so
we're going to put a negative right here
if we pick let's say negative 2.5 for
this interval we get a negative 2.5 plus
2 which is a negative
we get a negative 2.5 minus 4 which is a
negative and negative 2.5 plus 3 is a
positive and you can see here we're
getting a negative times a positive is a
negative
and we have a negative in the numerator
and a negative divided by a negative is
a positive so we're going to put a plus
sign here
in this interval let's go ahead and test
zero so if we put 0 in we're going to
get a let's see we're going to get a
positive in the numerator 0 minus 4 is
negative 0 plus 3 is positive so we're
getting a positive divide by a negative
which is a negative
and then the last one here let's test
five we get a positive positive positive
so positive divided by positive is a
positive now we're looking for Words
greater than or equal to zero so that's
where it's zero or positive
so that's going to be in these two
intervals right here and so if we write
that in interval notation that's going
to be from negative 3 not including
negative 3 so we're using the
parentheses to negative 2 okay we're
using the bracket because it includes
negative 2 Union
we're going from 4 to positive Infinity
now it doesn't include four it doesn't
include Infinity we put the little U for
Union and that's your solution at
interval notation
so let's try number 12 now
it says what is the slope between these
two points so you want to remember your
slope formula which is
Y2 minus y1 over X2 minus X1 and
remember you could think of this as 0.1
X1 y1 and 0.2 X2 Y2 the key thing is
when you're subtracting you want to keep
the order consistent so if I do this y
minus this y I want to do this x minus
this x if I go this y minus this y I
want to do this x minus this x you want
to stay consistent with the order so
let's go ahead and do this we have
negative 5 minus negative 4 right all
over negative 3 minus 2. so what makes
this a little challenging is all the
negatives and the other thing is you
want to make sure you keep the Y's and
the numerator x's in the denominator
sometimes students mistakenly switch
these When You Subtract it's like adding
the opposite so negative 5 plus 4 is
negative 1. again when you subtract it's
like adding the opposite so negative 3
plus negative 2 is negative 5 and a
negative divide by a negative is a
positive one-fifth
okay see if you can do number 13 and 14
. for 13 it says find the equation of
the line that's perpendicular to 2x
minus 3y equals 6 and it passes through
the point six negative 1. so remember
when you find parallel lines they have
the same slope when you find
perpendicular lines they have the
opposite reciprocal slope so that's
important to remember but the key here
is we have to figure out what's the
slope of this original line so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to subtract 2x
from both sides of the equation
and the reason I'm doing that is because
I want to get it into the slope
intercept form of the equation of a line
and to get it into slope slope intercept
form you have to get the Y by itself so
that's why I'm solving here for y so we
get y equals 2 3 x minus two now
remember this form y equals MX plus b
that M or that slope comes in front or
to the left of the X there so we know
the slope is two-thirds which means that
if we want to find a perpendicular line
it has to have that opposite reciprocal
slope which that means it's going to be
a slope of negative three halves so I
flip it and change the sign
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually use what we call the
point-slope form
of the equation of a line because we
have a point which is six negative 1 and
we have a slope so that's this form
right here so I'm going to say y minus
the y coordinate so that's y minus a
negative 1 which is y plus 1 because the
two negatives cancel and then we have
our slope and then x minus the x
coordinate of the point which is the 6.
now you can leave it like that that's
point-slope form that might be one of
your multiple choice answers or
it might be taking a step further by
rewriting it into this form the slope
intercept form by Distributing the
negative three halves we get negative
three halves X
negative times a negative is a positive
that's 18 over 2 which is nine
and then what I'm going to do is to get
y by itself I'm going to subtract 1 from
both sides so that's coming out to y
equals negative 3 halves X
plus eight
and that's your equation in slope
intercept form okay let's try number 14
now this one it says find the distance
and the midpoint between the points
negative 2 5 and 3 negative 7. so this
is kind of like a a twofer like two
problems in one or a a BOGO buy one get
one right so we actually have more than
50 questions uh in this review so let's
see so when we find the midpoint we want
to use this formula right here so this
is one you want to memorize it's
basically like taking an average you add
the X's together and divide by two and
you do the same thing for the Y's when
you find the distance formula we'll get
to that when we do the distance but
first midpoint let's add the X's so
negative two plus three
divided by 2 and add the Y so 5 plus
negative seven
divided by 2 so that comes out to one
half
and five plus negative 7 is negative 2
divided by 2 which is negative 1. so
that's our midpoint
now for our distance we're going to use
this formula another one to memorize X2
minus X1 squared plus Y2 minus y1
squared you add those together and you
take the square root and that's your
distance so in this case what we're
going to do is we're going to say
3 minus negative 2
so 3 minus negative 2 the quantity
squared plus negative seven minus five
quantity squared When You Subtract it's
like adding the opposite so we have 5
squared which is 25. this is negative 12
squared is 144. add this together you
get square root of 169 which is equal to
13. so that's our distance okay see if
you can pause the video and do number 15
and 16. this one says write the standard
equation of a circle with Center at
negative 2 3 and a radius of 5 units so
the equation that you want to know for
this problem is x minus H squared plus y
minus K squared equals the radius
squared and H and K represent the center
R is the radius right so in this case we
have h k that's going to be x minus a
negative 2 squared plus y minus 3
squared equals 5 squared and I would
simplify that a little bit further when
you subtract a negative that's like
adding the opposite so X plus 2 squared
plus y minus 3 squared is equal to 25
and that's the standard form of the
equation of your circle
okay for number 16 now is y a function
of X for this equation x minus 2y
squared equals 8. so what does that even
mean as y a function of X well it means
that for each x value do you just get
one y value and one way to do this is if
you were to graph this if you know what
this graph looks like you can do what we
call the vertical line test like say for
example if this was our graph which it's
not but let's say this is your graph you
can take a vertical line and go like
this and so for every X values there's
just one y value for every X values or
just one y value if there is
then that means that Y is a function of
X but if you don't know the graph what
you can do is you can solve for y you
can get this y by itself so what you can
do is subtract X from both sides so that
comes out to negative 2y squared is
equal to Negative X plus eight divide
everything by negative 2.
so that comes out to Y squared is equal
to positive one half x minus four and
instead of squaring let's take the
square root of both sides remember when
you take the square root of both sides
of an equation you get two answers plus
or minus
okay so this is plus or minus one half x
minus four okay so now you can see that
say for example if x was like eight
one half times eight is well that's a
bad example let's say if it was like 16.
so one-half times 16 is eight eight
minus four is four square root of four
is two plus or minus two so basically if
I put in 16
for X I'm getting uh what did I say it
was it was half of 16 is 8 8 minus four
is four square root of 4 is 2. so I'm
getting positive two or negative two so
for a given input or a given x value I'm
actually getting two different y values
so that means Y is not a function of X
you can kind of tell right here at the
this point because you can see oh if I
put an x value I'm getting plus or minus
two different y values but you can also
do some test values and test it out that
way as well or you can graph it so okay
see if you can do number 17 here this
one what we have is a piecewise function
and we're trying to evaluate what's f of
negative one equal to and what's f of
negative 4 equal to
so with these piecewise functions what
you want to do is you want to look at
these restrictions here you say well X
is less than negative 2 I use this
equation and when X is greater than or
equal to negative 2 I use this equation
so negative 1 is greater than or equal
to negative 2 which means that we're
going to put it in for X in the second
equation here so 3 times negative 1 plus
1 that's negative 3 plus 1 which is
equal to negative 2. so this is the x
value in the parentheses and this is
like the output or the Y value for Part
B now f of negative 4 negative 4 is
actually less than negative 2 which
means we want to use this top equation
and we're going to put negative 4 in
place of X so negative 4 squared minus 2
negative 4 squared is 16 minus 2 equals
14 and you got it
for number 18 it's asking what is the
domain of this
equation here well what do you think on
that one the main thing to remember is
that you can't divide by zero and you
can't take the even root of a negative
number so taking both of those into
consideration whatever is underneath the
square root here has to be greater than
or equal to zero but because it's in the
denominator it can't be zero so we're
just going to say 5 minus 2x has to be
greater than zero okay so solving this
inequality now let's just get the
variables on one side and the numbers on
the other
divide both sides by negative 2 and
remember when you divide by a negative
what happens to this inequality sign it
actually changes Direction so that's X
is less than five halves
sometimes I like to just graph this on
the number line just so I can kind of
visualize so it's anything less than
five halves so the interval notation
would be from negative Infinity to five
halves not including five halves
and you got that one
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 19 and 20. for 19 it's asking
us what is the range of this graph given
here now you want to remember the domain
is asking us what can the X values be
and the range is asking us what can the
possible y values be so in this case
when we think of the range I like to go
from low to high it looks like we're
basically from a negative one including
negative 1 all the way up to positive 2.
so I would write our range in interval
notation like this negative one to two
with the brackets because it includes
negative 1 and it includes two
as well as everything in between okay
for number 20 now it says describe the
transformations of this graph from the
parent graph y equals square root of x
now excuse me when you talk about
transformations
it's good to know about composition of
functions so if you think about this
square root of x function you can say
well how did I get from this to this
well see for example you had G of X is
equal to F of let's say X plus one so
what that tells us is whatever is in the
parentheses here is going to go in for X
on the right side of the equation so
that's going to make this square root of
x plus 1. but what does that X Plus 1
really do to the to the graph it's
actually going to shift it left one
now if we were to take this equation
right here and let's just say we have H
of X is equal to G of negative x what
does that do well it says okay we're
going to replace x with negative X so
now we have Negative X plus one so what
that tells us is this negative X is
making all the X values the opposite
which reflects it over the y-axis okay
so we started off with shifting left one
we reflected over the y-axis now let's
say we take maybe M of X and say m of X
is equal to 2 times h of X that's this
previous equation so what do we do here
we're multiplying this by 2
but what does this two in front do well
h of X is like the Y values or the
outputs the 2 is multiplying all those y
values by two so it's a vertical stretch
by a factor of two and then lastly let's
just say we had like n of x
and let's say n of X is equal to M of X
that's our previous function minus 3. so
what does minus 3 do it shifts the graph
down three so we would end up with 2
square root of negative X plus one minus
3 which is our equation here so you want
to do this vertical shift up and down
last we could have done the vertical
stretch first but usually I like to
start from inside of the uh radical like
that and work from the inside out the
mistake that students oftentimes make as
they say reflection over the y-axis
first and then shift left one when it's
grouped like this with the X like
underneath the square root or an
absolute value or a parentheses Etc
you're actually going to do this
addition or subtraction first followed
by this multiplication second it's
almost like the opposite of the PEMDAS
order that we normally follow but you
can kind of understand it if you build
up the function step by step by step
like this okay see if you can try number
21 and 22 21 says f of x is equal to x
squared minus 1 G of X is equal to 2x
plus 3 what is f of G of X so do you
remember what this represents here you
can also write this as
F of G of X like this and I actually
prefer this notation a little bit better
because what it tells me is that I'm
putting my G function into my f function
it's like working from the inside out
like we did when we worked with
parentheses now G of X is equal to this
quantity here 2x Plus 3.
and what we're doing is we're putting
that into the F function and remember
the way that functions work is
whatever's in the parentheses that's the
input we put that in for X on the right
so what we're going to do is we're going
to replace this whole quantity 2x plus 3
in for x
right here and then we're going to
square it and subtract 1. now remember
when you square a binomial you don't
want to just Square these two terms you
want to think of it as that whole
binomial times itself like you have two
of them
and then we'll subtract 1 here so if we
do the distributive property we've got
let's see 4x squared plus 6X distribute
the 3 that's going to give us another 6X
plus 9 minus 1. so now if we combine
like terms we see we have 4x squared
plus 12x Plus 8. and you've got that
composition of functions
for number 22 now we're given this
function f of x equals one half X plus
six but we want to find F inverse of X
so that's what that minus 1 represents
how do we find the inverse well the
easiest way I think to do it is to think
of f of x as like your y value
and what you do is you interchange the X
and Y so wherever you see X you put Y
and vice versa so this is going to be x
equals one half y plus six and now we
want to solve for that new y so what I'm
going to do is just work from the
outside in towards the Y by doing the
opposite operation so this comes out to
x minus 6 equals one half y we want to
get rid of the one-half so we're going
to multiply both sides by two and so now
you can see we're getting 2x minus 12 is
equal to Y because 2 times a half is one
and then instead of writing it like this
let's use the inverse notation so
instead of Y we'll write F minus 1 or F
inverse of X is equal to 2x minus 12.
and you got it okay see if you can do
number 23 24 25 and 26 for 23 it asks us
is the graph a one-to-one function so
what exactly does that mean a one-to-one
function well
when you do the vertical line test you
take a vertical line and you scan across
the graph it if it only crosses at most
one time then that means that Y is a
function of X okay but when you do the
horizontal line test
what you're testing for to see is the
inverse of that graph as a function so
in order for it to be one to one it
means every x value has only one y value
but every y value has only one x value
and so the way I like to think about
one-to-one functions is it has to pass
the vertical line test as well as the
horizontal line test this one you can
see if I draw a horizontal line
it's actually crossing the graph at more
than one point over here it only crosses
that one point only over here only one
point but if there's a point along this
uh vertical you know when I'm doing the
horizontal line test here as I raise
this line up here if it ever crosses at
more than one point then it means it's
failing that horizontal line test which
means the inverse is not a function it
also means that it's not one to one so
for this one we're going to say no
for number 24 25 and 26 these all go
together it's asking us what are the
coordinates of the vertex of the
parabola and these are all written in
three different forms so super important
to know these different forms so for 24
you recognize this as the vertex form
of a quadratic here so you can see that
H and K is going to be our vertex this
is going to be 1
comma negative 3. so the one that's
grouped with the X has the opposite
effect so if this is -1 this is going to
the right one this is plus one it would
shift it to the left one and this one
has the same effect it's going down 3
negative 3. okay so that's 24 now 25
this one here is in this form it's in
the y equals ax squared plus BX plus C
form and in order to find the vertex
here there's a formula you want to
remember it's this x equals negative B
over 2A and so you can see the opposite
of B would be positive 6.
over 2 times a which is three
so we get 6 divided by 6 which is equal
to one so the x coordinate of our vertex
is one now if we put one back in for X
we can find the y coordinate of the
vertex so 1 squared is 1 times 3 is 3.
6 times 1 is 6.
and so we have 3 minus 6 is negative 3
plus 1 is negative two so this one has a
Vertex at 1 negative two and then the
last one do you recognize this as being
in the intercept form
a times x minus P times x minus Q so
what it's really giving us here are the
two x-intercepts so if we were to draw
just a quick sketch of this it would
cross the x-axis at positive 2 and
positive 4. so you just set those
factors equal to zero
and that's where it's crossing the
x-axis at 2 and 4. because parabolas
they're symmetric
about the vertex if we find the midpoint
between two and four which you can see
is right here at x equals three the
vertex will lie on that axis of symmetry
so that tells us that the x coordinate
of the vertex is at three if we put that
back in for X here we can solve for the
y coordinate of our vertex so that's
going to be 3 minus two which is one
three minus 4 which is negative one so
we have one half times one times
negative one which is negative one-half
and so that means this would be
somewhere right here and you're getting
a parabola that looks something like
that but we're mainly after the vertex
so three good forms to to memorize
okay before we do number 27 and 28 do
you see what just happened we actually
crossed the halfway point so let me know
in the comments below if you're still
with me and you stuck uh through it to
this point but let's see if we can dive
into these problems uh sketch the
polynomial so we're given this
polynomial and it's already in factored
form so how do we get like a good sketch
or a rough sketch at least of this
polynomial well you can set all these
factors these groups equal to zero to
find your x-intercepts or your zeros so
if I set x minus 1 equal to 0 I get x
equals one
and if I set X plus 3 equal to 0 I get
negative 3
and if I set x minus 4 equal to 0 I get
a 4.
okay so those are our x-intercepts those
are key points now the other thing we
want to pay attention to is this leading
coefficient see how it's negative so
negative tells us that the graph is
going to be going down to the right okay
and the degree of this polynomial which
this is understood to be one for this
factor is going to be one plus two is
three plus three is six so it's a even
degree six degree which tells us the end
behavior to the left is going to be the
same as the end behavior to the right if
it's odd it's going to be the opposite
direction it would go up
now the other thing we want to pay
attention to is What's called the
multiplicity meaning how often does that
zero occur does it just occur once or in
this case twice or in this case three
times and how does that affect the shape
of the graph at the x-intercept or the
zeros so in this case at negative 3
because this is a even degree okay when
it's an even degree like 2 4 6 it's
going to essentially have like this
almost like Parabola shape where it
bounces it changes Direction it just
Touches at that point
and then over here at one this is just
going to cross just like a line
basically okay just go straight through
so when it's an odd degree it's going to
go through and then over here at 4 it's
also odd so it's going to go through as
well but it kind of has like an X cubed
shape so you could kind of go almost
like you're gonna
bounce but then it ends up going through
like that now this is just a rough
sketch some other important points you
might want to watch for would be like
the y-intercept where it crosses the
y-axis and you could find that by
putting 0 in for x and solving for the
y-intercept the other thing you can do
too is you can plot some additional
points in between these zeros or these
x-intercepts to get a sense of
potentially how far down it goes or how
up it goes you kind of learn more about
this when you get into calculus one
but the main thing is the end behavior
and the x-intercepts and then the shape
at the zeros so for number 28 how can we
describe the end behavior of this
polynomial
okay now assuming we can't use a
graphing calculator what we want to do
is we want to look at what happens as
you go to the right and what happens is
you go to the left so let's write this
notation we'll say as X approaches
negative Infinity that means we're going
to the left
f of x which refers to the Y values
approach blank and then we're going to
do the same thing as X approaches
positive Infinity that means we're going
to the right f of x are the Y values
approach blank okay I like to do the
right end behavior first because this
leading coefficient this number in front
of the highest power of X is going to
tell us whether it goes up or down when
it's negative it tells it's going to go
down to negative Infinity if it was
positive it would go up towards positive
Infinity the degree this highest power
of x if it's odd it's going to go the
opposite direction when we go to the
left which means that since this was
negative this is going to be positive
Infinity if it's an even degree it's
going to have the same end behavior one
way to remember this is uh you know how
x squared see how these are going both
up or if it was a negative x squared see
how these are both going down that's
even right it's the same end behavior
whereas if you look at a x cubed
it's going in the opposite direction
like like this okay now this is a basic
notation sometimes in calculus or even
in college algebra your teacher might
show you this notation instead of as X
approaches negative Infinity you'll see
the limit as X approaches negative
Infinity
f of x approaches like that so you might
see the limit notation or this as X
approaches notation
so good job on that one okay see if you
can do number 29 and 30 for number 29
it's asking us to divide and notice that
we're dividing by a linear Factor see x
to the first so we can use our synthetic
division when you do your synthetic
division
what you want to do is you want to take
the opposite so x minus 2 you want to
make this a positive 2 if this was X
plus 2 you'd make this a negative 2. and
then what you do is you take your
coefficients the numbers in front of
your variables One X to the fourth
notice that we skip from X to the fourth
to x squared we're skipping over X cubed
so we have to put a placeholder 0x cubed
3x squared negative 6X and 2. then you
drop down that first number you multiply
on the diagonal and you add straight
down you multiply on the diagonal you
add straight down you multiply on the
diagonal you add straight down and you
multiply on the diagonal and you add
straight down and this last number is
our remainder because we started out
with X to the fourth and we're dividing
by x to the first this goes down by one
degree so this is X cubed plus 2x
squared plus 7x plus 8 plus 18 over x
minus 2. you put the remainder over the
divisor and that's your quotient there
okay for number 30 we want to find all
the zeros of this polynomial function
and what you could do here is you could
use the rational root theorem the p over
Q the way you do that is you take all
the factors of the constant meaning all
the numbers that go into 18 which would
be 1 2 3 Let's see 6 9 and 18 divided by
all the factors of the leading
coefficient which would be one or two
positive or negative so it could be 1 or
1 half or two or nine halves you know
positive negative like that so it kind
of Narrows down which ones we want to
test using our synthetic division
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start off with let's say negative 1. so
if I do the synthetic division with
negative 1 we have 2 x to the fourth we
have 4X cubed negative 16x squared
negative 36x and negative 18 and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
bring down that first number we're going
to multiply in the diagonal and we're
going to add straight down we're going
to multiply on the diagonal and we're
to multiply on the diagonal add straight
down multiplying the diagonal add
straight down you can see we have zero
remainder which tells us that negative 1
is a zero so we found one of our zeros
and we also brought this down from X to
the fourth to X cubed now we could
continue to search for additional zeros
and
you want to find all of them but what I
notice here is that we can actually take
what we have left here and Factor it
that's not always the case you might
have to bring it down to like a
quadratic and then Factor through the
quadratic formula to find the remaining
zeros but in this case it looks like we
have four terms we could Factor by
grouping and so I'm going to factor out
a 2x squared which gives us X Plus 1 and
I'm going to factor out a negative 18
which gives us X plus one so if we
factor out the X Plus 1 we're left with
2x squared minus 18 which we can Factor
this by pulling out the 2 that's x
squared minus 9 and then that's a
difference of two squares X plus 3 x
minus three
so now if we set these factors to zero
we're going to get X plus one equals
zero which would be negative one
and X plus 3 equals zero which is
negative three
and x minus three equals zero that would
be x equals three and we had this one
over here negative one so basically
negative 1 occurred twice
which that's important to notice because
sometimes when you do the synthetic
division
sometimes students will forget about
negative one but you might want to check
it again to make sure you know it's not
like a double zero
and so these are going to be all of our
zeros in this particular problem and
just keep in mind if it's a fourth
degree you should have four zeros it's a
third degree three zeros etcetera okay
for number 31 it says write a polynomial
with integer coefficients that has the
roots two and negative I so how do we do
that one well the key thing to notice
here is why are they making such a deal
about having integer coefficients or
even just uh real coefficients well what
that tells us is that if you have this
negative I you're going to have the
complex conjugate also as a zero so this
would be negative I you would also have
positive I if it was 2 minus I you'd
have 2 pulse I so you have that
conjugate and then when you give are
given the zeros the factors are going to
be x minus the zeros so we have x minus
negative I which is X plus I and x minus
I now what you can do is I'd probably
foil these together here first because
you can see the ins side and outside are
going to cancel this is going to give us
x squared and this is going to give us
negative I squared but we know I squared
is negative 1 times a negative is
positive 1. so we have x squared plus 1
and we have x minus 2. so now we just
have to multiply these together x times
x squared is X cubed x times 1 is x
negative 2 times x squared is negative
2x squared and negative 2 times positive
1 is negative 2 and I would just write
this in descending order so this would
be like f of x is equal to X cubed minus
2 x squared plus x minus 2 and you got
that one for 32 now we're graphing a
rational function this one right here so
remember how to factor or you remember
how to factory a we'll definitely have
to factor this but remember how to graph
these so the first step is to factor the
numerator and denominator as much as you
can so X Plus 1 and x minus 1 and then
for the denominator
you're going to factor that one as well
and that factors to x minus 2 x minus 1.
now this is interesting because a factor
in the numerator cancels with a factor
in the denominator if you set that x
minus 1 equal to 0
this tells us that we're going to have a
hole at x equals 1. now to find the y
coordinate of the whole what we're going
to do is we're going to plug that 1 back
in that's going to give us 2 over
negative 1 which is negative 2. so we
have a hole at 1 negative 2. so let's go
ahead and put that on our graph now as
far as graphing this it's basically
going to looks like look like y equals
X Plus 1 over x minus 2 with this whole
so what you want to do is graph the
asymptotes and you can see that you can
never divide by zero so by setting x
minus 2 equal to 0 we get x equals 2 and
that gives us our vertical asymptote
right here at x equals 2. and then
notice that there's a tie between the
highest degree term and the numerator
and the denominator see x squared and so
what happens when it's a tie like that
is you get the ratio of the coefficient
so y equals 1 over 1 which is y equals 1
is going to be our
horizontal asymptote if the degree in
the denominator is bigger say if this is
X cubed then it would be y equals 0
right at the x axis and if the
numerator's degree was higher by one
like say this was X cubed and this is x
squared then you'd have to do some long
division or synthetic division and you'd
get like an oblique or a slant or a
diagonal asymptote
now what I like to do is go ahead and
find the X and y-intercepts and the way
you can do that is by sending X to 0 or
Y to zero so if I put 0 in for X you can
see we're going to get negative one half
so that tells us it's going to cross
right here 0 negative one half and then
if we set y to zero the only way that y
would be zero is if this numerator is
equal to zero because zero divided by
something that's not zero would be zero
right so if we set y equal to zero that
means that occurs when X is negative one
so that tells us that x intercept is
going to be right here at negative one
so already you can have a pretty good
sense of what's happening with this
graph it's going like this
approaching the asymptote the vertical
asymptote and the horizontal asymptote
let's pick another point maybe over here
to the right of this vertical asymptote
let's put in x equals three so that
would be 4 over 1 which is just 4. so
this should be a point here at 3 4 and
you can see that this graph is going to
be approaching the asymptotes like that
so good job if you're able to get that
one okay for number 33 now it says if R
varies inversely as T and R equals
three-fifths when T equals one-half what
is the value of R when T equals
one-fifth so what they're testing us on
here
is the inverse variation so you can see
that r
Aries inversely with T so when it's
inversely the variable goes in the
denominator if it was direct the
variable would be in the numerator would
be R equals a times t
so now we have to solve for this a value
this constant of variation some teachers
use the letter K other books use even
other letters besides that but it's
usually a or k they give us some
information they say when R is equal to
three-fifths
what's t equal to one half so what we
can do is we can multiply both sides of
this fraction by one half
to get this a this constant of variation
by itself so that comes out to 3 10 is
equal to a so we're going to take that 3
10. we're going to put it back into our
equation right here for a
so that comes out to R equals 3 10 over
T so that's our inverse variation
equation but now we want to find out
what is r when T equals one-fifth so
let's replace t with one-fifth remember
when you divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal
so I just move that up there and you can
see now the 5 and the 10 cross reduce so
that comes out to three over two so R
would just equal three halves and you
got it
okay for number 34 it says if two
thousand dollars is invested at six
percent compounded monthly
how much will the investment be at the
end of five years okay so that's
interesting so compounded monthly so the
formula you want to know here is the
compound interest formula which is this
one right here you might want to write
this down memorize this
and you can see p is the principle
that's what we're starting with that's
the two thousand dollars the interest
rate six percent we're going to write
that as a decimal .06 n is the number of
times you compound in a year so monthly
is 12. this n and this n are the same
and we want to know how much you'll have
after the end of five years and so let's
go ahead and put that in our calculator
let's see what we get
so that comes out to two thousand one
plus point zero six divided by 12
12 raised to the 12 times 5 which is the
60th power so this is coming out to
2697.70 so you want to round to the two
decimal places that's the pennies and
you got okay for number 35 and 36 we're
getting into some logarithms so for 35
it says evaluate log base 3 of 1 81st so
what a lot of students like to do that I
work with they like to write this as an
equation like set it equal to like some
variable like X and then what you can do
you can think of log base 3 like
logarithms and exponential functions are
inverses of each other so what you could
actually do is exponentiate or raise
both sides using the same base three so
log base 3 and exponential function base
three they're inverses they like undo
each other kind of like squaring and
square rooting so now we just have to
answer this question 3 to what power
equals 1 over 81 well we know three to
the fourth is 81 but because this is the
reciprocal this is going to be negative
4. so negative 4 is the value of log
base 3 of 181st
for number 36 we want to graph this law
graph here
and what we can do is we can make use of
some Transformations so see this plus
one this shifts the graph left one
and the minus 2 shifts the graph down
two so we could think of this kind of
like our new starting point kind of like
our new origin then we can focus in on
this parent function y equals log base 3
of X just like we did in this last
problem what I would do is I would
exponentiate both sides of the equation
so what that'll do is these are inverses
are going to undo each other so you have
3 to the Y power equals x we can make a
table and what we'll do now is we'll put
in values for y so we'll say negative 1
0 and 1. so this would be 3 to the
negative 1 is 1 3 3 to the 0 power is
one and three to the first power is 3.
now we're going to plot these
coordinates not from the original origin
but the shifted origin because of the
plus one and minus two so from here I'm
going to go right one third down one
should be right about there then I'm
going to go right 1 up 0 that's right
about there and then I'm going to go
right three one two three up one
and you can see if you want to find the
vertical asymptote set this quantity in
parentheses equal to zero X is equal to
negative one that's going to be your
vertical asymptote right there and your
graph is going to look something like
like that so the domain would be X is
greater than negative 1 and the range
would be all real numbers okay for
number 37 we're going to be expanding
and for 38 we're going to be condensing
logarithmic Expressions so how do we do
this well the first thing we want to do
is realize that we have a division
problem here so we divide what do we do
we're going to subtract so this is
really going to be like natural log of 5
e cubed minus the natural log of 6.
notice the 5 and the E cubed are next to
each other that means they're multiplied
together and when we multiply when we
expand we write it as a sum so this
would be natural log of 5. plus natural
log of e cubed and then minus natural
log of 6.
natural log is really a log base e and
what happens here is that log base C and
exponential function base e those are
inverses of one another they cancel each
other out so we're really just left with
three so if you expand this you could
write this as natural log of 5 plus 3
minus natural log of 6 and that's about
as much as we can really do on that one
for 38 though now we're condensing so
when we condense we can use the power
property these coefficients in front of
the logs we can bring up as Powers okay
so this these are all going to come up
as exponents so we can write this as log
of x to the fifth minus log of Y squared
plus log of Z to the fourth power and
remember when we add we multiply and we
subtract we divide so if we combine this
all into one log which notice there's
not a base so that's understood to be
base 10. it's a common log this would be
log X to the fifth times Z to the fourth
divided by because we're subtracting y
squared and that's as much as we can
condense that one okay for number 39 it
says solve this logarithmic equation so
how do we do that one well what I would
probably do first is I'd condense these
into one log so I'd say this is log base
2 of x divided by x minus 1. Remember
When You Subtract you divide the
arguments and that's all equal to 3. now
we want to get the variable by itself
but you can see it's kind of inside of
this logarithm so what we can do is we
can exponentiate both sides the
exponential function base 2 and the
logarithmic function base two those undo
one another kind of like squaring and
square rooting and 2 cubed is 2 times 2
times 2 which is 8. so now all we have
to do is think of this as eight over one
we can cross multiply so that's going to
be 8X minus 8.
is equal to x times 1 which is X we'll
subtract X from both sides and we'll add
8 to both sides
and so you can see that's going to give
us 7x is equal to 8. so we divide by 7
you can see that X is coming out to 8 7.
now one thing you want to be careful of
with these log equations is you want to
make sure you're not taking the log of 0
or a negative number so if I put 8 7 in
minus 1 that's still positive and 8 7
that's positive so this is a good answer
so for number 40
it says if money is invested in an
account that pays five percent interest
compounded continuously how long does it
take to double so this is kind of the
the key phrase here compounded
continuously when you compound
continuously you want to use this hurt
formula a equals p e to the RT so what's
interesting it doesn't say how much
money we're investing so normally we put
our principle in for p but here we're
just going to leave it as P but since
we're looking at for how long it takes
for it to double the a is the ending
amount that's going to be 2 times p
e is our natural base e the interest
rate is five percent so we're going to
write that as a decimal .05 and then the
time is what we're actually trying to
solve for so if we divide both sides by
P these are going to cancel and then
what we can do is we can take the
natural log of both sides so if I take
the natural log of 2 that and that's
going to equal the natural log of e to
the 0.05 T natural log is log base e
these are inverses of one another log
base C and exponential function base e
so now we have natural log of 2 is equal
to .05 T we just have to divide by 0.05
both sides and that's going to give us
our time to double let's see what that
comes out to
looks like it's going to be about
13.86 years
okay see if you can pause the video and
do number 41 and 42 so for 41 we have a
system of linear equations we want to
find out where these two lines intersect
how would you do this one well if I was
going to do this problem I would notice
that we know what Y is equal to this
whole quantity here so what I would do
is I would do the substitution method
and put that in for y in the second
equation if we do that we get 3x minus 2
times instead of Y we're going to put
what y equals that's one half X plus
four and that whole quantity equals
negative 16. now we just have one
variable and one equation we can solve
this system so if we distribute we get
Negative X minus 8 bring down the 3x
and now we can solve so we've got 2X
and if we add 8 to both sides
you can see we have two x's equal to
negative eight if we divide both sides
by two you can see that x equals
negative 4. now if we take the negative
4 put it back in for X here or here we
can solve for y let's do the top one
that's a little bit easier one half
times negative four is negative two plus
four is equal to two so now we know y
equals two so when you write your final
answer you want to write it as a x y
coordinate negative 4 comma 2 that's
where these two lines are going to
intersect
now for number 42 we're dealing with
some complex numbers
complex remember they're part real part
imaginary that's what the I represents
the square root of negative one and so
we're going to do is we're going to add
the two complex numbers subtract them
and then multiply them see if you can do
that one on your own so if I was going
to do it when you're adding you're
basically just combining like terms so
you're saying 2 plus negative 1 is equal
to one three I plus 4i is equal to 7i
you can almost think of i as like a
variable like X or Y or Z
now for letter B when you're subtracting
this one's a little bit more challenging
what I sometimes like to do is think of
this whole thing as a group and so I
want to put it in parentheses I'm
subtracting this whole quantity negative
1 plus 4i remember when you subtract you
can think of this as adding the opposite
so you can change these signs in here to
the opposite or you can think about it
as Distributing in a negative one now
it's just like the previous problem
we're adding you're just combining like
terms 2 plus 1 is 3 3i plus negative 4i
is negative 1i and you always want to
write your answer in the a plus bi form
you put the real number First and the
imaginary number second
and then lastly when we multiply you can
think of this as
foiling these together you're
multiplying them together so it's like 2
times negative 1 is negative two two
times four I is 8i
and then 3i times negative 1 is negative
3i and then 3i times 4i is 12 I squared
but what does I squared equal
I squared is negative 1. so remember I
represents the square root of negative 1
but when you square both sides I squared
is just equal to negative 1. so this
gives us negative 12 plus negative 2
which is negative 14 and then if we
combine the 8i and negative 3i that
comes out to positive 5i and now you've
got it in the standard form of a complex
number
okay for number 43 and 44 see if you can
do these ones on your own so for this
first one you can see that we've got
these two expressions on the left and
the right side and it's really helpful
if you can get the bases to be the same
because if the bases are the same then
that means the exponents have to be the
same and you can set those equal and
solve so in this case what I'm going to
do is I'm going to look at this 5 and
I'm going to notice that this is really
like 5 to the one-half power if this was
the cube root it'd be the one-third
power or the fourth root one fourth
power and so that's the left side of the
equation now the right side I want to
get this also to have a base of 5. 125
is 5 to the third power five times five
times five but because it's in the
denominator this is going to be a
negative exponent the negative you take
the reciprocal now what you can see when
you have a power to a power what do you
do to these exponents you multiply them
together so that's going to give us one
half times two x which is One X and one
half times negative six is negative 3.
you just want to distribute that one
half and then over here negative 3 times
x is just negative 3x so now we've got
it where we want it where we have the
bases the same we just have to set the
exponents equal to each other so that
means that x minus 3 is equal to
negative 3x if we subtract X from both
sides we get negative 3 is equal to
negative 4X and if we divide both sides
by negative 4
you can see that we're getting X is
equal to 3 4 and you got it okay for
number 44 this one
we're not able to get the basis to the
same like we did over here because 2 to
what power is 10 it's not going to be a
nice value so what we're going to have
to do here because the variables in the
exponent position is we're going to have
to rewrite this in the logarithmic form
so the way you would do that a couple
different ways is you could take the log
base 2 of both sides
that's one way to do it and then you can
see the log base 2 and the exponential
function base 2 those are inverses of
each other they undo one another and so
now we're just left with x minus 3
equals log base 2 of 10. so all we have
to do now is add 3 to the other side
and that's going to be log base 2 of 10
plus 3. you could leave it like that
that's an exact answer or we can go to
the calculator and get an approximation
so let's do that and see approximately
what this is log base 2 of 10
plus 3 so I'm getting approximately
6.32
and you got it okay see if you can do
number 45 and 46 so 45 is asking us
given this table is this a linear or
non-linear function
well if I was going to take a look at
this I would notice that with the Y
values I'm going down by 7 down by 7
down by seven I'm subtracting 7 each
time with the X values I can see that
I'm going up by one
up by 1 up by 1 and you can see that the
change in y over the change in X meaning
you know how are the Y's changing
compared to how the X's are changing if
we divide negative seven by one we're
getting negative 7 negative seven
negative seven so basically what this
tells us that this is going down at a
constant rate with a slope of negative
seven so this would be a linear
function
if it wasn't going at a constant rate
either positive negative then we would
say you know it's non-linear
so for number 46 how would you solve
this quadratic equation you can use any
method you could do the completing the
square you could try factoring you could
try graphing it and seeing it where it
crosses the x-axis you could try
guessing and checking you could try the
quadratic formula a lot of different
techniques but this one I think because
you know the a value is not one I think
if we were trying to complete the square
we'd have some fractions in here might
be a little challenging so let's go
ahead and use the quadratic formula and
remember this is in the form ax squared
plus BX plus C equals zero and our
quadratic formula you want to memorize
this as negative B plus or minus the
square root of B squared minus 4AC all
divided by 2A so if we substitute our a
equals three our B is equal to 2 and our
c is equal to 4 into this equation we
get negative 2
plus or minus B squared which is 2
squared that's 4 minus 4 times a which
is 3 times C which is 4 all divided by 2
times a that's 2 times 3 which is 6. if
we simplify what's inside the square
root here we get let's see negative 12
times 4 is negative 48 so 4 minus 48 is
negative 44.
and we have negative two plus or minus
the square root of negative 44 over 6.
and notice we're taking the square root
of a negative number when you do that
you get an imaginary number we can think
about this as square root of negative
one times square root of 4 times square
root of 11. square root of negative 1 is
I square root of 4 is 2 so we could
think of this as 2i square root of 11.
and then now what you can see is that
this group this group and this group are
all divisible by 2. so if we reduce this
divide everything by 2 we're going to
get negative 1
Plus
1i root 11 over
3 plus or minus and then what you can do
is you can split this up into two parts
you could do this real part in this
imaginary part so you could say negative
one-third
plus I root 11 over 3 or negative 1 3
minus I root 11 over 3 and then you have
it in the a plus bi form that real part
first imaginary part second okay see if
you can do number 47 and number 48 on
your own so for 47 we're given this
polynomial graph here and it says what
is the minimum degree of the polynomial
now when you're given a polynomial like
say if you had something like
y equals x to the fifth plus dot dot dot
dot whatever the highest degree is like
for example if this was a fifth degree
polynomial if you subtract one that
tells you the maximum number of turns or
bends in the graph so in this case you
can see that the graph is bending or
turning one two three times so that
tells us that the degree of the
polynomial would have to be a 4 or
higher now this is asking us the minimum
degree of the polynomial so when I see
that when this is X to the fifth for
example and I subtract 1 that's the
maximum number of bends that's four
bends in the graph of course it could
have less
and if we're working backwards here if
you see there's three bends here then
the minimum degree of this polynomial
would be
and plus one so it would be 3 plus 1 is
4. so this is basically a fourth degree
would be the minimum
degree of this polynomial and then here
it says where is the graph increasing
now increasing it's like reading a book
like when you read from left to right
like that you're looking at for where
the graph is going up to the right so it
basically has kind of like a positive
slope in a sense like it's going up to
the right as X values increase the Y
values increase so you can see that's
happening here
and here and that's happening from
negative one
to zero
and it's happening here from one
onward
and now notice I'm using the parentheses
because it doesn't include this point
because at this point it's kind of going
decreasing it's almost kind of like
changing direction almost horizontal
like constant and then it starts
increasing so you don't want to include
those points where it's changing
direction that's why we always use the
open interval or the parentheses so
negative one to zero not including
negative one or zero and one to Infinity
not including one or Infinity
for 49 we're graphing an exponential
function see if you can graph that one
and if I was going to do this one I
would notice that this one and this
three what is this doing to the graph
the one is going to be Shifting the
graph right one the three is going to be
Shifting the graph up three so what we
could do is go right one up three kind
of think of this as like our new origin
kind of like our new starting point kind
of like our new x-axis and y-axis in a
sense and then what we'll do is we'll
focus in on this parent function just
the Y equals 2 times 1 3. to the X power
let's plot a couple of easy values maybe
negative one zero and one if I put one
third to the negative first Power the
negative exponent tells us to take the
reciprocal that would become three times
two is six zero anything to the zero
power is one times two is two notice I'm
doing the exponents first then the
multiplication second that's the order
of operations one-third to the first
power is one-third times two gives us
two-thirds we're going to plot these
points not from the original origin but
through from the shifted origin so I'm
going to go left one up six
okay then here we have zero left or
right up two
and then one two thirds so right one up
two-thirds right about there so you can
see what's happening is this graph is
decreasing it's an exponential decay
function the reason it's decaying or
decreasing is because that base is
between zero and one and if we wanted to
ask ourselves what the domain is it
would be all real numbers the graph
basically goes to the left and the right
forever and ever the range would be
everything that's greater than 3 or you
could say the range is from 3 to
Infinity sometimes they'll ask you for
this horizontal asymptote that the graph
is getting closer to that's a horizontal
line that's the line Y is equal to three
they might ask you you know what the
y-intercept is in this case there's no
x-intercept so those are some typical
problems let's go to the last problem
number 50. okay before we do this last
problem let me know in the comments
below if you're able to get through this
entire review video and let me know how
you did but before we also finish this
last problem if you want additional help
with these type of Concepts and you like
the way that I explain things check them
my video courses in the description
below I've got an algebra one and an
Algebra 2 college algebra video course
that goes more in depth into all these
Concepts and more so check those out for
this last problem we've got a system of
three variables three equations how
would you solve this one see if you can
pause the video and do it on your own if
I was going to do this one what I would
do is I would look at a variable that I
want to eliminate either the X's the Y's
or the Z's and I think in this case the
easiest thing for us to do would be to
work with the Y's because I have a
positive line and a negative y if I were
to add these two equations together the
Y's would cancel out we'd have 1X plus
2X is equal to 3x 3z plus 1z is 4z and 4
plus 7 is equal to 11. okay we've used
the first and second equation we want to
use all three equations so I need to use
this third equation and I need to stick
with that same variable that I'm
eliminating which in this case is the
Y's so what I'm going to do is I'm going
to combine this third equation with the
second equation and if I add these two
together you can see the Y and negative
y are going to cancel one another out so
if we do that excuse me we get 2x plus
1X is 3x
1z plus 2z is 3z
and seven plus two is nine
excuse me now we wanna
solve this system where we have two
variables two equations and we want to
pick a variable to eliminate now in this
case it looks like it's going to be
easiest to eliminate the axes but what
I'm going to do is I'm going to multiply
this bottom equation by negative 1 which
is going to make this negative 3x minus
3z equals negative 9. now if I add
straight down 3x minus 3x is 0 4z minus
3z is one Z and 11 minus 9 is 2. okay so
now we know what Z is we went from three
variables three equations to two
variables two equations one variable one
equation now we want to back substitute
if we do that let me put Z either in
here or here I'll do this top equation
that's going to give us 3x plus 4 times
2 is 8 equals 11. subtract 8 from both
sides that's 3 and divide both sides by
three you can see that X is coming out
to one okay so now we know one n I'm
sorry x and z we want to find out what Y
is we want to go back to one of the
original equations that has the three
variables let's go ahead and use this
top equation if x is one why we don't
know 3 times Z 3 times 2 is 6 equals 4.
so we have 1 plus 6 is 7. so y plus 7
equals 4 and if we subtract 7 from both
sides you can see we're getting y equals
negative three when you write your final
answer you want to write this in
alphabetical order X comma y comma Z
that's a triple and you can check your
answer by putting these back into all
three equations you should get four
seven and two just verify that you got
the right answer so great job if you're
able to get through all of those good
luck on your final and good luck with
your math studies I'll see you in the
next video